the Federal Reserve keeps raising
interest rates to fight inflation today
it's at nearly four percent and we
continue to anticipate that ongoing
increases will be appropriate but what
about the interest rates that make you
money like on your savings account right
now the average savings account pays
less than a quarter of a percent but
some savings accounts are going up just
as fast as the feds you know a lot of
what your experience for what's happened
with savings rates really depends on
where you're looking here's why most
savings accounts are lagging behind the
fed's rising rates and which ones aren't
let's start with why a bank pays you
interest in the first place it's because
well they need your money Banks use the
deposits people keep with them to fund
loans like for cars or credit cards and
they profit off of that interest
basically they need these deposits in
order to make money which is why they
entice you with savings rates this is
great that a particular bank is paying
as a reflection of their desire for
additional deposits or their attempt to
retain the deposits that they have
that's it Greg McBride works at Bankrate
which compiles this data on savings
accounts we survey financial
institutions for rate and fee
information on a wide range of consumer
banking products and there is a wide
range all in competition to keep your
money a traditional savings account with
your regular Bank isn't the only safe
place there's also online savings
accounts which traditionally pay more
interest than your local brick and
mortar bank then there's CDs or
certificates of deposits basically the
bank will pay more in interest but only
if you keep that money with them for a
set amount of time it's similar to a
government treasury bond you earn more
interest but your money is tied up not
readily accessible like these savings
accounts but with all these choices if
the rate Rises on one it usually
pressures the others to rise too usually
if banks want to retain deposits they've
got to keep Pace with what government
bonds are yielding otherwise Sabers will
take their money out of the bank and put
it in government bonds those government
bonds are yielding High interest rates
though they are keeping up with the
fed's rising rates so why aren't these
savings accounts the answer lies in the
this chart the amount of money currently
held as deposits at Banks you can see
this huge Spike here in 2020 where
people stop spending started saving and
received stimulus checks the banks were
flush with deposits and they still are
experts like Greg say not only do big
Banks not need to attract deposits but
also see Rising rates as an opportunity
well interest rates were at record lows
for years and so what happened was that
squeezed Bank interest margins Banks
don't want to pay more in interest than
they're bringing in right for a long
time even before the pandemic the feds
kept interest rates low meaning the rate
they profited from like car loans was
also low now that the fed's rate is
going up meaning these rates are too
they're not going to increase the
savings rate unless they really have to
and overall banks have so many deposits
right now they don't a lot of the bigger
banks in particular they're sitting on a
mountain of deposits they have more
deposits and they know what to do with
so the last thing they're going to do is
raise the the cost of that so who is
paying a competitive rate online
accounts often called high yield savings
accounts are offering savings rates as
high as 3.5 percent banks that are eager
for deposits that have a growing loan
operation and need to feed that machine
by bringing in more deposits they will
pay increasingly competitive rates these
types of accounts are still FDIC
protected like any Bank you just have to
transfer money in and out of them online
which could take a few days as opposed
to being able to make a same-day
withdrawal in person if you're not
taking any risk would you rather earn
three and a half percent or would you
rather earn 0.01 percent I mean that's a
slam dunk that's easy so why isn't your
savings account going up with the fed's
rising rates it could be because you
have your money in the wrong place